[Music]  adèle celebrates turning 30 with a  Titanic themed birthday bash I figured  life's a gift and I don't intend on  wasting it you never know what hand  you're gonna get dealt next the Grammy  winner channels her inner rose Dawson  rocking a similar beaded dress to the  one Kate Winslet wore in the 1997 flick  when Leonardo DiCaprio well Jack Dawson  joined her for a first class dinner and  below deck dancing after saving her life  to make meat counter this soiree  included a recreation of the grand  staircase and lifevest props which the  singer and her guests wore while hitting  the dance floor and if that weren't  enough Adele even sported a replica of  roses diamond and sapphire heart of the  ocean necklace 56 carats to be exact  following the bday party Adele shared a  few snaps from evening writing thank you  to my family and friends for  entertaining my super fandom of the  Titanic movie last night was the best  night of my life  you